in the last few minutes president trump
has tweeted
saying that he and the first lady have
tested
positive for covid 19. let's go straight
to los angeles and our u.s correspondent
greg milam morning to you greg i mean we
knew this was a possibility
but this is going to play really big in
the states isn't it
yeah it is i mean this is a tweet five
to one in the morning in washington and
that tweet from the president saying we
will get through this
uh together but you're right that it's
been it's been coming in the last couple
of hours and
i can take you through what happened
excuse me hope hicks who's one of the
closest if not the closest adviser to
donald trump
uh was confirmed a few hours ago as
having tested positive for covid19
now she has been traveling with the
president uh throughout this week she
was on that trip to cleveland in ohio
for the presidential debate on tuesday
she was with him uh on a trip to a rally
in minnesota on
on wednesday now on that trip to
minnesota she'd had a test she was found
to be negative before travelling
she began to feel unwell on the trip and
quarantined on the plane back she'd been
on air force one and marine one with the
president
she tested positive when she got back
and that was on on wednesday night
and as a result of that in the last few
hours the president confirmed that he
and the first lady had been tested for
covet 19
they were in his words beginning the
quarantine uh
process and they expected the result in
the next few hours
and and that result is what we've just
got back in in the last
few minutes what's interesting is that
the white house knew that hope hicks was
positive on on wednesday night
washington time
but still the president went ahead uh
yesterday with the visit to his golf
course
in in new jersey in bedminster that was
for a fundraiser
so even though they knew he'd been in
close contact with someone
uh who would uh who had tested positive
that trip was allowed to go ahead
uh and it's only in the last few hours
that that quarantine process
has begun and that will be a 14-day
quarantine process
we wait to hear from the white house
what the protocol is now under
guidelines from the centers for disease
control
you would assume the president is
considered an essential worker so he
will be
able uh to continue to do his job uh
from the white house
you would imagine although that there is
the possibility that the vice president
mike pence will be able to step
in but all of this of course in a in an
election campaign an events plan for the
next few days and weeks
as he seeks a re-election this is a real
bombshell from a man of course who has
always
downplayed his own vulnerability to this
virus
yeah i mean and and of course this is
gonna bring back
all the things that he said right at the
beginning of all of this isn't it
even down to him claiming at one point
that this was
all just a hoax i mean in terms of the
the presidential campaigning and what
the democrats
and those republicans who are against
trump are going to say
i mean this gives them almost an open
goal doesn't it
[Applause]
yeah when you go back to the very
beginning and of course in the
presidential debate earlier this week
joe biden made a great play of the fact
that
donald trump early on and said this
would disappear like a miracle he he
mocked the fact that donald trump had
talked about
injecting bleach although donald trump
said he was being sarcastic of course
hydroxychloroquine the president said he
had taken a course of that
to make sure that he didn't he didn't
get the virus himself
and yet and yet here we are like his
ally in brazil who had downplayed the
risks
but then was was tested positive it's
happened and donald trump has as i say
has downplayed his own vulnerability he
very rarely wears a mask himself as we
know he carries one he showed it on the
debate stage
but he very rarely wears that mask some
of those around him do those who come
into close proximity in the white house
are tested every day but
we see the pictures of him traveling and
certainly to the debate earlier this
week not all of them
not all of them wearing masks and he's
continued to hold those rallies and that
one in minnesota this week is an example
thousands of people
uh packed together in those in those
rallies not many of them are wearing
masks a lot of them will tell you they
don't they don't believe that the the
virus is a great risk
to them otherwise they wouldn't be happy
to jam together in in those events
without masks
he says that they're open air events and
that is that is true so the risk is less
but
this will be a a pretty sobering moment
for those who are supporters of the
president and have heard those those
messages
and it goes to the heart of course of
his of his whole handling of this
uh pandemic and and that suggestion that
there have always been mixed messages he
said people didn't need to wear masks
and then he did wear a mask uh said it's
up to people to to do what they want
he's talked about reopening the economy
he's talked in recent weeks about
america rounding the corner
uh in in in facing down this this
pandemic
in the face actually of what some of his
medical experts have been
uh have been saying and here he is now
uh himself testing positive and and the
first lady as well
what's interesting is that on his
schedule for friday and he may well
continue to work from the white house of
course even in quarantine
he was due to speak to as due to hold a
call on support for the elderly
uh who was suffering uh from covid19
well we should remember he is in that
group he's he's 74
years old he is one of the the
vulnerable
people more vulnerable group of of the
population from this virus